hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
the internet was probably the single
most revolutionary technology of the
20th century it has defined much of
modern life from streamers cat videos
and memes to educational content and
whistle blows the list of what the
Internet has brought along with it is
endless some good and some bad but with
the power to connect everyone the
Internet itself has led to a strange
phenomena the solving of mysteries even
some crimes may have never been solved
without such an interconnection between
people let's dive in starting with
reddit and a cold case reddit is a
community referred to as the front page
of the Internet there's a staggering
collection of communities forming
through subreddits where users can post
about specific topics
one such subreddit is called RBI or the
reddit Bureau of Investigation's
it's one of the many subreddits
dedicated to amateur detectives solving
crimes and mysteries for example in 1995
an unknown hitchhiker was killed in a
car accident in Virginia the
unidentified man wasn't wearing a seat
belt the hence sustained injuries that
hindered his identification a
handwritten note referred to the man as
Jason so he became known as Jason Doe
this is because the police couldn't
identify his last name the note had a
phone number for no area code leading to
a dead end for 20 years the case laid
dormant until 2015 when a Reddit user
zombie grave began researching the case
for herself after posting reconstructed
images of Jason zombie gray was
contacted by someone who said that the
image looked a lot like his old roommate
Jason who he hadn't seen for twenty
years
Jason's mother also saw the images which
led to a positive DNA test confirming
that the body was in fact her late son
this gave her closure albeit 20 years
later
the Internet has also been used to save
Liars
in 2013 a California teen by the name of
Jackie Rose us had been following the
tumblr blog of a depressed girl in New
Jersey one day the girl had blocked that
she was going to commit suicide
Jackie jumped into action but without
knowing the girl's last name or even
what part of the country she was in
Jackie had a difficult task ahead of her
with a small amount of information
extracted from the girl's Tumblr posts
Jackie got the police involved with the
lead the police gave a photo of the girl
to the local high school but they said
that she didn't attend that school
diving into the tumblr post they
discovered that she posted about loving
the UHS marching band they had to find a
County or a town with those initials
searching through even more old Tumblr
posts and YouTube videos the police and
some other concerned citizens began
trying to decode the location Heather
Allen an officer at the local high
school pieced together that it was a
Union Township in New Jersey from a
fragment of a newspaper article the
police contacted their colleagues in New
Jersey who immediately dispatched to the
teen's house they found her overdosing
on medication and rushed at a hospital
just eight hours after Jackie had raised
the alarm the girl was found and saved
it's fair to say that the actions of
Jackie saved her life and this wasn't
the only time that the Internet solved a
mystery that led to saving someone's
life
in 2015 already use a poster on the site
saying something odd
he'd been finding random post-it notes
around his apartment the post-it notes
were reminders of tasks that he needed
to do the strange thing was he hadn't
spoken to anyone about these tasks he
started freaking out was someone else in
his apartment how did they know his
schedule the man began to suspect that
it was his landlord that was placed in
the notes he asked reddit for legal
advice in reply one user in the reddit
community suggested that perhaps the man
writing the notes was himself the reddit
user suggested checking for a carbon
monoxide leak sure enough after the man
set up a carbon monoxide detector in his
apartment he discovered high levels of
the odorless gas a leak had caused the
man to black out and forget about
writing the notes in fact the level of
carbon monoxide was so high that it
could have been deadly so not only did
the combined knowledge of the reddit
community help solve this mystery but it
may have saved this man's life as well
other online mysteries are simply just
strange in 2013 a mysterious youtube
channel was created that raised a lot of
questions the channel only uploaded
specific creepy videos with different
sized red and blue squares on a white
background a constant ringing tone was
the only audio to add to the mystery the
channel uploaded at a rate of one video
every 20 seconds he would have the time
to do this and what was its purpose the
internet community was puzzled the
channel only uploaded two videos that
didn't fit this format the first was a
short cartoon clip which cost the viewer
two euros and was only available in
France the second was a video of the
Eiffel Tower lit up at night
the channel had only ever made one loan
comment on the Eiffel Tower video the
comment stated Matei is highly
intelligent he was this mysterious Matei
there was a lot of questions the
Internet community began working to
decipher the cryptic videos the puzzle
remained unsolved for several months
until an Italian blogger crafted it
turns out that the channel was made by
Google Zurich office in order to test
video upload quality a simple end to a
mysteriously confusing channel actor
Shia LaBeouf wasn't happy about the
results of the 2016 presidential
election so he decided to make an art
installation with the words he will not
divide us on a wall there was a camera
live streaming so people could come to
the wall and say whatever they wanted
the problem was people from 4chan kept
messing with it so he moved the location
of the art installation and it happened
again fed up Shia LaBeouf decided to put
up a flag with the same words in an
unknown location so nobody could mess
with it this time it was just a live
stream of the flag with the sky in the
background and that would make it
impossible to tell where it is
right wrong 4chan saw this as a
challenge soon people across the globe
began scanning every pixel of that live
stream they analyzed flight patterns
from the condensation trails of the
aircraft in the background they looked
at weather patterns and wind velocities
constellation locations in the sky and
even the sounds of the wildlife around
the area combining all of their
knowledge within one day they found
where the flag was and they messed with
it it just goes to show that when many
minds are put together onto a shared
problem it can be solved easily this is
an inconsequential example but perhaps a
more personal one was that time when
4chan with very little information
managed to find an Isis training
facility in Syria and cold in a Russian
airstrike to get the place bombed so a
bunch of trolls on the internet put the
heavily funded CIA NSA and FBI to shame
an even more amazing example of this is
how gamers on the internet came together
to push medical science forward
[Music]
research into curing diseases such as
cancer has been slowed down due to a
natural problem with the way that
molecules fold and tRNA is a game
developed by researchers trying to crack
these real-life mysteries and create new
medications after the game was released
hundreds of thousands of people flocked
to the site users began learning about
how molecules fold and the rules that
govern that folding the community grew
and soon non-experts began reading about
science and teaching each other these
gamers actually beat a supercomputer in
a molecule folding challenge as a result
many of the molecules designed by users
have been deployed in tests to create
new medications and make leaps towards
cures for diseases by 2011 over 300
designs were synthesized and results
were even published in medical journals
with gamers being listed as co-authors
the company also has biomedical
challenges where users focus their
efforts on common goals open TB
challenges users to find a way to use
RNAi to detect tuberculosis in the gene
structure of patients while open CRISPR
focuses on improving the quality of
CRISPR technologies Foldit is another
game which has much the same purpose as
a tRNA but focuses on proteins instead
in this case the power of the people
over the Internet has been used to solve
mysteries governing our natural world
pretty amazing stuff so the Internet has
had a dramatic effect on the way that we
communicate and what we do with that
information but so far it's also been
used to solve cold cases prevent suicide
fight terrorism and potentially create
medical breakthroughs as more people
from the farthest reaches of the world
gain internet access
who knows how we'll use this power of
connection and what mysteries will
finally be uncovered and solved but more
importantly it also goes to show that
when we all put our minds towards the
common goal we can easily achieve it
through our distributed mental ability
always your favorite mystery solved by
the internet and leave a comment if you
know of any other stories in the comment
section below stop just about wraps up
the video thanks for watching this has
been - go go and you've been watching
cold fusion
if you did like this video I want to see
more interesting stuff you should
definitely consider subscribing so I'll
see you again soon for the next video
cheers guys
[Music]